có cơm mới của Haley and Pong Nils cho thấy hồ chương Mỹ là nấu tiền dơi khỏi to mời của gia có quyền lực nhất trong 2 thực tị qua.
Sẽ bị chi tương mề 2 của Malaysia, kếm tổng gặp 3 mì sống của giả khác về số điểm miễn tị thực.
Còn giới Mỹ hiện được miễn visa tại 1 trong tảm người trong số 2 chăm hành bệ của gia và phụm lãnh thổ chính thử giới.
Dạm sau với mức giận đầu từng đặt đúng năm 2018.
Sự tụi thằng nay phản anh ta đồng của những thay đổi trong quan hiện ngoại giao và chính xác tị thực trên tàn cầu.
Viện URSU chăm rất miễn visa cho công dân Mỹ, cùng su hướng mở giọng miễn tị thực của Trung Quốc và nhiều cuối xa trộng a thái mình dân.
Đàn khiến cán cân ảnh hưởng quan cầu nguyên dần khỏi Washington.
Xin gặp bò, hành Quốc và trịt bàn tiếp tục uống giẫn đầu bằng xếp hạn, với khả năng li tới gần 2 trong cuối xa mặt không cần visa.
Rồi quan xin nhận định là bằng xếp hạn mới không chỉ đau lường khả năng dị truyền.
Mặc còn xả lánh vị thế mềm của cuối xa trong trận tự của tế đang thay đổi nè chống.